hey guys I'm Joey back with another
unboxing and this time I'm here with
Miguel and we're going to be unboxing
the final fantasy 12 zodiac Age
collector's edition so if you could tell
me a little bit about this what we're
going to be seeing here 505 C 12 the
zodiac age is an enhanced remaster of
what a lot of people consider to be one
of the best Final Fantasy's filefast e12
came out in 2006 we gave it a 9 out of
10 I happen to be reviewing the zodiac
age and we should have a review up
sometime early July cool and if you want
to see that make sure to subscribe but
let's go ahead and open this up oh yeah
you wanna get that fine I'll get this
side there's no tape so we no need for
the razor blades quite yet this is a
this is technically a retail sample
assembled for us specifically by Square
Enix alright we'll get that site again
open up in tandem oh yeah we got this
art here turned Oscar this way wow we
actually have quite a bit of art here so
as someone who has followed the series
that's right
who's the artist ago don't look at the
signature you should know these things
alright let's let's take a look at the
cases first so we have the steelbook
right here which might be plastic but
there is um again this is a pre-release
retail sample provide to provided
directly to us by square so we have
brought a placeholder from the
from the eleven-year-old original game
gate and a soundtrack yeah I think
soundtrack - yes any soundtrack there
you go there's kind of what it will look
like when you open it up all right we
also have I think it was a some card say
set postcard collection postcard
collection let's open that one up so
let's see we go if you could tell me who
are these characters these are the
heroes of final fantasy 12 not counting
world of ivelisse so we got a short
skirted ash we got this uh lizards vase
Vaughn Vaughn and then we got Bosch and
balthier and fran and penelo
fron yeah vanilla and penelo and then
this is oh we just got the entire world
on a postcard they they're glossy oh you
can you said these are postcards but I
don't think you'd be able to send it
because the bag also has their logo on
it you can pass them around the office
alright and then I think the big thing
here is the the set of five busts the
judge magistrate Magisters oh yeah let's
pull those out yeah a bus is basically a
statue of a human from the chest to the
top of the head
it looked like that okay now we're
breaking out the razor blades for this
look you didn't get all of it off David
okay I got it
all right so if you can oh wow that's
some factory scented no plastic
chemicals like machinery all right do
you know who these characters are here
yes you can say it all right let's start
with stars is let's start on this in
saga path dark Zarda wait okay sorry go
back go nicer look oh yeah by the way
this is $200 retail um so if so we just
go right here
that's our go bad that's good
don't look at the ball it doesn't but
that's bergen I can tell people then
this one's grabbed gabranth Gibran a
brand grace and gets so what's well
they're quite the quite detailed there I
think I would say the weight is about
what I expected there isn't like too
much half but it definitely doesn't feel
all along yeah they're not made of metal
but it's very very solid plastic I'm
assuming or some kind of you know but
chemically these polymer or whatever
yeah if you told the child that this was
metal that probably you and then they
live their life believing
everything wrong about metals no where's
a load three yes but it has a teen
rating yeah there's actually a few
warnings on this box oh no it actually
contains sharp points because as you can
see some of them have some video
dangerous helmets this one right here
some points to it so it's these are not
toys by the way these are not toys
they're not for children under 13 either
is that it that's it I think that's it
so telling it all up we have the game
with a steelbook there the six post
cards flip through it this is all your
game is no there's no art book no but
the placement that you have the six post
cards and then the five heads of these
dudes here turn not toys again beautiful
so Miguel yes now that we have seen
what's inside here and we also know the
price of $200 I know that you didn't buy
this but would you buy actually I have
pre-ordered it and I will keep my
pre-order because it's actually my
favorite JRPG of all time so I would
recommend that recommend this to people
who considered it to this to be a
favorite JRPG I know final fantasy 12 is
a pretty big following it has a very
unique combat system I really enjoy the
characters and the job system also has
been overhauled and so far I've been
enjoying playing around with it told ok
that was it for the final fantasy 12 the
zodiac Age collector's edition now if
you want one for yourself you can still
pre-order them there are $200 and they
will come out on July 11th I believe
right correct ok so yeah if you want one
go ahead and do that and make sure to
subscribe to catch our next unboxing see
you guys later
[Music]